bonjour à tous la rgpp révision générale
des politiques publiques a été lancé par
le gouvernement en juin 2007
elle vise à changer l'organisation
administrative française en améliorant
le service aux usagers les conditions de
travail des agents et en réduisant l la
dépense publique
le sénat a décidé d'étudier les
conséquences de cette rgpp sur les
collectivités territoriales
la mission d'information présidée par le
sénateur socialiste françois patriat
s'intéresse à la méthode adoptée aux
moyens mis en oeuvre et au résultat de
cette rgpp
la mission sénatoriale auditionne pour
cela elle les ministres concernés ainsi
que les principaux acteurs locaux la
semaine dernière elle auditionné alain
rousset le président de l'association
des régions de france
on écoute tout de suite cette audition
alors le bol est question que nous
posons sous couvert de rapporteur nous
avons déjà maintenant depuis trois mois
auditionné à la foi de responsables de
l'état des collectivités locales des
communes des communes rurales des
départements nous restent et les régions
et régions aujourd'hui sur comment et
ressentir région comment est vécue en
région d'hommes se retire ma casquette
de près dans une région à l'enterrement
parce que il m'a semblé que les régions
avaient été informés par les préfets
localement il n'avait pas ressenti
directement eux les
les impacts de la de la rgpp
autour de ces trois objectifs initiaux
la simplification l'optimisation les
économies qu'ils devaient engendrer
on a eu depuis maintenant des
évaluations qui ont été faites de part
et d'autre des initiés
elles ont été faites par le gouvernement
elles ont été faites par françois baroin
avait été faite en conseil des ministres
elles ont été faites par la cour des
comptes dont est faite aussi sur le
territoire nous avons élargi un peu
dominique notre notre investigation en
disant bon y'a la rgpp services de
l'état sont sues stricto l'état mais
nous avons pu voir en déplacement dans
le lot lundi bien qu'il n'y en ait pas
eu l'impact aussi des différentes cartes
qui ont été mis en oeuvre depuis depuis
2007 tenir la réforme
la carte judiciaire la carte militaire
la carte spital hier les cartes
scolaires qui ont été mises en place et
qui ont bien sûr un pack tv les
collectivités je citais pour exemple ce
matin là r f
par exemple la réforme les cartes
scolaires qui ont un impact direct sur
les collectivités locales en termes de
construction de classes d'aménagement de
locaux de construction de laboratoires
de construction de cantine de gymnase et
puis aussi de matériel acquis
aujourd'hui obsolète par la fermeture de
tel ou tel
voilà alors se trouverait dont nous
voudrions avoir connaissance c'est
comment les régions de france perçoivent
la rgpp haskell en perçoivent gérard
miquel nous a dit que pour sa part il
comprenait que l'état ya une forme de
consensus sur la nécessité de réformer
l'état de l'alléger de l'assouplir de le
rendre plus efficient plus efficace
moins coûteux mais comment ça a été
ressenti par les régions temps voilà
voilà monsieur le président chers banal
l'essentiel on laisse faire président
général un propos liminaire
et puis ensuite le rapporteur et moi
nous posons les questions et les
collègues un shell ceux qui sont ici
aujourd'hui poseront des questions en
sachant qu'on tiendra forcément les
horaires j'imagine telles questions au
gouvernement
et puis nous nous avons d'autres vous
dit voilà merci président merci françois
moi je vais commencer par une
observation d'ordre général sur la rgpp
d'un constat tout simple la rgpp c'est
un peu la tondeuse à gazon
serge rase d'une manière uniforme tous
les services de l'état
on l'a vu dans la défense on l'a vu dans
l'éducation
on a vu dans les services extérieurs de
l'état et 7 se fait d'araser d'une
manière indifférente les services de
l'état il suffit de l'exprimer pour
exprimer aussi les limites de l'exercice
en règle générale en règle générale un
chef d'entreprise aurait conçu qu'une
réorganisation de ces entreprises
auraient tenu compte des produits qu'il
voulait vendre des entreprises qui
marchait bien et puis des entreprises
qu'ils allaient filialiser ou fermés
parce que c'était plus son job
or la conception de la rgpp
pour des raisons que je j'ignore
peut-être de poids de l'appareil d'état
des organisations syndicales par absence
de vision
le po de large et pépé a été important
indifféremment appliquée et souvent et
souvent douloureusement douloureusement
vécus je crois que philippe seguin
disait lui-même tout ça pour ça si c'est
pour ne pas remplacer un fonctionnaire
sur deux on a peut-être intérêt à aller
au delà et comment les régions n'ont
vécu les régions n'ont vécu à la fois
avec beaucoup de surprise et puis en
même temps parfois d'agacement pour une
raison très simple c'est que aujourd'hui
l'état veut revenir à travers ses sous
préfet notamment dans les aidant les spl
dans les services publics locaux veut
revenir dans des compétences qui sont
liquides dont il a perdu l'ingénierie
les sous préfets font des réunions à la
demande de l'état dans des bassins
d'emploi sans moyens sans a dégénéré si
la région sont pas là il n'y a pas gagné
1 de générer des moyens donc par rapport
à la décentralisation tout ça n'est pas
rationnel au niveau de l'enseignement
les régions sont amenés à doter les
lycées professionnels notamment parce
que c'est ce qui est le plus lourd en
matière d'équipement en même temps on
ferme des sections matériel n'est pas
utilisé on modifie on me dit filer les
préconisations dans l'été dans les
différentes dans les différentes
sections et on pourrait citer on
pourrait citer plein d'exemples parce
que cette mécanique qui est une
mécanique d'économie apparentés 2d
budgétisation fonctionne partout d'abord
moi j'aimerais savoir c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs une chose que votre
commission pourrait interroger
quel est le coût d
consultance d'appel à consultant auquel
l'état fait appel depuis qu'il a diminué
son ingénierie parce que sert à rien de
diminuer les services
si dans le même temps on fait appel à
des conseils extérieurs
donc quel est le niveau de la
consultance se consacre aujourd'hui
c'est que l'état notamment maîtrise
d'ouvragé directe
on le voit au niveau des universités
perd tout son ingénierie j'ai eu pour ma
part à discuter sur les plans campus
avec la ministre madame pécresse qui m'a
avoué ne plus savoir ne plus avoir des
compétences repas elle ses services de
réhabiliter une université et de devoir
faire appel aux ppp public très dont on
sait aujourd'hui le coût colossal
d'abord en terme de jeu reporte l'impôt
sur mes enfants et le coût immédiat sur
les universités et leur autonomie les
universités vont devoir faire appel
comme variable d'ajustement soit en
régions soit droits d'inscription on se
trouve dans un système où la rgpp est
plutôt que ceux d'hier comme en effet
n'importe quel chef d'entreprise part
dans cette référence
je concentre mes moyens mais compétences
dans ce que sont les compétences
régaliennes de l'état
mais je veux rester partout à la fois la
tour de contrôle juste ce site ces mots
parce que c'est une discussion que j'ai
eue avec nadine morano à la fois la tour
de contrôle mais en même temps en même
temps dans le poste de pilotage de
l'avion et dans la soute à bagages pour
remplir les remplir la soutenir
c'est par rationnelle c'est pas
rigoureux c'est pas responsables
fallait-il supprimer 8000 à 9000 postes
de policiers fallait-il supprimer m à
loos l'éducation nationale fallait-il
des budgétisé avec le grand emprunt les
crédits
recherche en baissant les crédits
récurrents du cnrs et de l'inserm et en
faisant des appels à projets à travers
le grand emprunt faut sûrement faire
émerger l'excellence mais on sait depuis
hier rapport pisa que l'excellence
neiman que 2 que si on n'élève
globalement la basse est valable pour
les élèves c'est valable pour la pour la
recherche
et alors ce qui est insupportable en
plus pour les pouvoirs des concentrés
c'est qu'on se trouve mais françois
patriat pour en témoigner
autant que moi c'est qu'on se trouve
devant un état qui a perdu son oeil
générique qui a perdu ses moyens
financiers mais qui veut commander le
cas de l'apprentissage était un cas
caricatural on veut doubler le nombre
d'apprentis sans comprendre que d'abord
ça dépend de l'entreprise qui a un taux
d'échec dans l'apprentissage qui est
considérable de 10% supérieur à suite
l'échec scolaire qu' on ne peut pas
développer l'apprentissage en changeant
tous les six mois les accompagnements
les exonérations tout le système
financier juridique et fiscal sur lequel
l'incitation de l'apprentissage fade
faut sûrement c'est tout le paradoxe on
considère qu'en france on considère et
je partage à que le coup de la décision
publique
c'est à dire le poids de
l'administration et que le temps de la
décision publique en france est plus
lourd et plus longue qu'ailleurs ça
signifie qu'il ya peut-être pardon de le
dire comme ça ça fera peut-être d'en
dire trop de fonctionnaires en france
enfin de fonctionnaires et de parra
service public
je reviendrai avec l'exemple du service
public de l'ombre à toute heure mais en
tout cas c'est pas comme ça qu'on s'y
prend d'abord l'état n'a pas le droit de
perdre de la compétence
j'étais hier en commission de la défense
nationale à l'assemblée on entendait le
râble
celui qui va piloter ballard nous dit
l'état ne sait pas faire ne s'est pas
construit un pentagone à la française
c'est monsieur bouygues qui a gagné qu'à
la compétence l'état ne s'est pas
réhabilités comment s'appelle cette
université amiantés jussieu quelque part
c'est choquant quoi c'est choquant que
l'état perdre de la compétence dans ce
qui est et de l'ingénierie dans ce qui
est ses compétences et c'est tout autant
choquant que l'état garde des services
jeudi pas des services publics jeudi des
services et des agents dans des
compétences qui ont été transférées aux
collectivités locales l'état est
responsable des doublons d'être y plonge
pas si ces français qui existent
aujourd'hui pour gérer les fonds
européens
c'est la région c'est les régions qui
met les contreparties mais en même temps
c'est l'état qui veut en gérait une
partie ils gèrent moins bien globalement
parce qu'ils ont moins de monde et on
pourrait dire pour les départements la
même chose sur la solidarité et l'action
sociale
on finir revenons à une forme de
neutralité de l'état
revenons à une organisation rationnelle
des services comme ça on diminuera le
coup de la décision publique et le temps
aussi de la décision publique et une
analyse qui est très précise qui a été
fait sur la gouvernance de l'innovation
en disant il faut qu'ils aient une seule
gouvernance de l'innovation
aujourd'hui il ya un bout de drire
direct maintenant ça s'appelle un
boudeuse et aux bailleurs et foulée les
agents d'oseo charge et de conseil en
innovation sont en train de disparaître
au profit des banquiers il ya de la
région ça n'a pas la rationalité cette
organisation trônait le service public
de l'emploi
aujourd'hui le service public de
l'emploi est fait au moins de 4 à 5
strates successives la strate pôle
emploi qui connaît une crise énorme
parce qu on a mélangé des métiers qui
n'ont rien à voir le métier de
l'indemnisation est le métier de la
réinsertion
les missions locales pour les jeunes
mais les communes et les
intercommunalités ont mis en place des
tas de dispositifs les régions aussi
or aujourd'hui le problème de l'emploi
n'a pas de pilote n'a pas une
organisation de l'information régionale
est une organisation de la mobilité
nationale le monde de la formation ne
parle pas au monde de l'entreprise
et ça marche pas il ya des secteurs en
tension
ce qui est insupportable il ya des
chômeurs qui sont en galère et en règle
générale le chômeur qui est plus de six
mois termine devant le bureau du maire
pour être embauché dans les services de
la ville tout ça c'est pas de la
rationalité des services publics
donc moi quelle confiance puis-je avoir
dans l'état qui donne des leçons de
rationalité qui n'est pas capable de se
les appliquer à lui-même ses succès
n'importe quelle entreprise aurait mis
la clé sous la porte
quinze fois avec cette gestion donc ok
pour la rgpp
mais mais mais une rgpp intelligente à
qui on a besoin on a besoin de gendarmes
on a besoin de policiers on a besoin de
juges
notre un diplomate on a besoin d'eux on
a besoin de 2
on a peut-être besoin d'enseignants on a
peut-être besoin de chercheurs on a
besoin d'eux on a besoin d'avoir un
poste de pilotage sur la politique
industrielle de référence d'un lieu de
stratégique sur la politique
industrielle on a plus de politique
industrielle maintenant à parler à part
la dgr on a besoin qu'on paye
correctement les fonctionnaires
des services de l'état de telle sorte
qu'il ne parte pas tous que les
meilleurs ne partent pas tous dans le
privé parce que il faut aussi parler de
ce problème
comment la fonction publique est-elle
rémunérés quand on est dans des
fonctions stratège et que vous gagnez 10
fois plus dans le privé moi il m'a été
fait une confidence dont je ne peux pas
dire d'où elle vient
que l'expert de la dette français
étaient veolia je crois tu es passé chez
veolia et que nice a des finances était
obligé de passer par lui pour avoir des
conseils je le tiens ça d'une de son
patron mais de l'époque on est dans un
système hallucinant quoi c'est pas ça
être latron donc les régions à la fois
son voit qu'on convient lors donner des
leçons pour les stratégies d'emploi
local pour les stratégies d'emploi
régional pour l'accompagnement des
entreprises pour alors que les services
n'existent quasiment plus d'ailleurs
prenez le cas des prenez le cas d'eads
et du grand emprunt et des
investissements d'avenir les services de
l'état ont été complètement tenus à
l'écart parce qu'ils de tout cela bon et
en même temps on a besoin de services de
l'état dans un certain nombre de
domaines
ils sont plus là dans les compétences
régaliennes
on n'a plus besoin de sous préfet on n'a
plus besoin de drire de drass de draft
de choses comme ça on sait c'est pas ça
le service public aujourd'hui c'est pas
c'est pas une espèce de 2,2 de
protection paternaliste nom n'a pas
besoin de ça finie la décentralisation
c'est la responsabilité
par contre dans les responsabilités
régaliennes de l'état la suppression
d'un certain nombre de tribunaux
notamment des tribunaux de commerce qui
pouvait aider à la solution d'un certain
nombre de problèmes industriels
moi je peux vous dire que ça a était
grave pour l'aménagement du territoire
voilà très schématiquement trop
longuement ce que je peux vous bien
sur le dernier point je je réagis un peu
quand les rêves dit préfecture ne
travaille pas avec ce profil sur ses
vraies traz rire mais les maires
parce que nous l'objectif de notre
mission c'est à dire un pacte la rgpp
sur les collectivités locales
or les primaires peu ils ont besoin d'un
sous-préfet en tant que conseil
non maintenant conseil aujourd'hui il ya
plus contrôle de légalité nommé ils le
ressentent moi j'ai quittant la mission
l'autre jour je suis allé le soir avoir
oui merci de me le vernis c'est le
syndrome de stockholm c'est le syndrome
de stockholm enfin la france est le seul
pays
c'est le seul pays jeu on est obligé de
diminuer ou deux d'or de rationaliser
dande plus rigoureux la dépense publique
et encore une fois le coût de la dépense
publique le coup de le will coût de la
dépense publique le coût interne de la
dépense publique est plus fort en france
que dans les autres pays c'est pas
contestable bon la réponse à
l'accompagnement des collectivités
locales de base à l'émiettement communal
c'est l'intercommunalité c'est pas le
sous préfet pourquoi déresponsabilise
dont les maires des petites communes
pour choisir un équipement sportif comme
un équipement d'entreprise commun nos
deux va je veux dire tant qu'on
maintiendra les sous-préfets on
maintiendra les maires des petites
communes dans un état de l'absence de
responsabilité et de tutelle fin
80 mais pour le pour le maire qui a qui
a construit des cas et qui a par exemple
aménager son père lui il est content
d'avoir à côté de lui
services de l'état pour faire le plein
ont payé l'avocat du diable
je sais bien je sais bien je te remercie
de me tendre la perche comme ça on peut
se tutoyer d'antigue hobbit est comme ça
où je dis est ce qu'on peut concevoir
aujourd'hui le pnud d'une commune sans
regarder l'intercommunalité
est-ce qu'on peut concevoir les schéma
d'urbanisme sans les concevoir de
manière collective
on voit très bien ce que nous vivons il
était président d'une communauté urbaine
la plaie ce que j'ai essayé d'arrêter
j'ai été maire d'une commune de 60000
habitants de banlieue dont une partie
était rurale
les premières décisions que j'ai pressé
d'arrêter l'étalement urbain
et si au niveau de l'intercommunalité on
se dote pas de moyens alors peut-être
que les conseils généraux peuvent les y
aider d'une certaine manière
beaucoup de conseils généraux d'ailleurs
ont mis sur pied des des structures des
taux des deux communes ill et la région
cofinance des agences d'urbanisme à
l'échelle régionale
justement pour servir d' aide aux
petites communes ou aux communes
regroupées et quelle quelle est la
compétence d'un sous-préfet particulière
sur le plan d'urbanisme je sais pas par
rapport à au secrétaire général d'une
intercommunalité qui doit être du même
niveau
honnêtement je sais pas par contre par
contre sur le plan de l'urbanisme on
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure que le
maire de je ne sais plus quelle commune
du de charente avait été mise en examen
j'avais vu ça sur sur un certain nombre
de permis de construire par contre que
l'état que l'état fixe d'une manière
forte
un certain nombre de principes globaux
pour les pour la sécurité pour les
mesures d'intérêt général je pense
notamment au tracé lgv ou à il
appartient à l'état de le faire je ne
nie pas l'état le soin de le faire nous
nous venons de vivre en aquitaine en
midi pyrénées en limousin un phénomène
inverse sur le tracé de la lgv l'état
alors pourtant prévenait le préfet a
laissé faire des lotissements dans des
lieux dans des lieux qui était tellement
évident pour le tracé de l'autoroute
qu'on se pose des questions
l'état a laissé faire des lotissements
prête pour certaines communes la l'état
l'état aurait dû intervenir pour fixer
ce plan là mais qu'est ce que c'est dans
le détail où l'organisation non non il
l'a fait une fois qu'on a lancé le
dossier du rapport après le le propos du
président c'est je sais pas si on peut
poser des questions parce que je veux
dire que la la vision que vous exprimer
tout à fait tranché
je voudrais revenir sur deux a priori où
il je veux dire que voulait dire
beaucoup de choses sur le droit des sols
d'urbanisme oh mais c'est pas le sujet
de donneurs de nos travaux
vous avez dit d'entrée de jeu que la
rgpp j'ai noté ces tondeuses à gazon
uniforme jeu j'entends ce que vous dites
je crois que ce que voulaient exprimer
par là c'est que on n'a plus tous les
pans du d'activité de l'état et puis on
est passé avec la tondeuse à gazon
pourtant dans les auditions nous avons
un fait souvent les collègues nous ont
dit non pas le sentiment plutôt que
d'affirmer des choses mais moi j'ai le
sentiment avec dock avec que la tour 2 à
gazon n'est pas si uniforme que ça si je
prends le un sur deux qui est un peu le
symbolique
j'ai le sentiment que de ce papy qui est
tout à fait de la même façon à l'échelon
central à l'échelon régional et un
échange local
première observation voulez-vous vous
entendre le dessus deuxième observation
qui est un peu un débat théorique mais
moi j'aimerais entendre le représentant
des des régions de france sur ce sujet
moi j'ai le sentiment que lorsque l'état
réfléchit à sa réforme sa réorganisation
l'appliquons on peut on est parti dans
la logique du rapport balladur au fond
l'échelon pertinent de l'action publique
était la région et au fond les préfets
de région ont été dotés d'une mission de
coordination des services de l'état
et puis la déclinaison territoriale au
niveau du département
c'est plutôt le bras armé de la
structure d'état au niveau régional ce
que nous avons votée au parlement tout
moins ce qui ressort c'est que le
département ne sort pas faibli sens
plutôt renforcé est donc deuxième
question est ce qu'il n'ya pas
des connexions entre l'organisation de
l'état qui conforte les selon un
régional est une réalité des
collectivités territoriales qui reste
malgré l'action des régions qui reste
très départementale et puis une
troisième question que plus d'ordre
anecdotique mais j'ai l'impression que
vous y avez répondu dans la tonalité de
votre propos est ce qu'à un moment ou un
autre
vous avez été sinon associer tout au
moins concertées dans l'application de
la rgpp au niveau régional faisait très
fièrement
très clairement non non de celle enfin
j'ai pas je ne sais pas si françois
patriat était lui-même
non c'était comment oui bon les nouveaux
deux autres questions chaudes sont sont
très importantes
un jeu et moi j'essayais de développer
tout à l'heure quelque chose de cohérent
du point de vue des régions par rapport
à une organisation rationnelle des
pouvoirs publics et donc par rapport au
poids de l'administration par rapport au
poids de ses pouvoirs publics au poids
de l'emploi public paraît gestion de
l'action publique
à l'évidence je partage aussi votre
votre sentiment que l'administration
centrale a été totalement épargné et
singulièrement merci et le souvenir du
successeur je crois de dominique strauss
kahn qui avait essayé l'échec de
christian sautter pour pour parler pour
parler clair a dû peser dans l'est dans
les discussions entre le ministère et
les organisations syndicales
à l'évidence le poids de
l'administration centrale
même le poids du service de
communication de bercy
et à s'interroger une certaine manière
ce qui pose d'ailleurs un vrai problème
si on le portion poursuit le
raisonnement sur la relation de l'état
de ses services et de nos concitoyens
quelle appréhension peut-on avoir dans
la société si on est dans le bunker des
ministères c'est assez mais en tout cas
je partage je partage ce sentiment et
sur le deuxième point quel est le niveau
territorial pertinents moi j'ai coutume
de ne pas opposer départements et
régions sur le plan de la
décentralisation ce que je crois
profondément c'est que l'heure n'est pas
né on est plus c'est un débat de la
quatrième république voire même d'un
troisième république
des concentrations décentralisation le
problème n'est pas là aujourd'hui le
temps de la décentralisation de la
responsabilité venu quand une fois alors
bien sûr je parle de là où je suis mais
la france est le seul pays et vous
n'imaginez pas à quel prix qu'un choc
culturel y compris dans la sortie de
crise
la lutte contre l'échec scolaire
l'imagination sur la sueur sur la
créativité industrielle la recherche
d'action sociale la france est le seul
pays où l'interlocuteur du président de
région du président de département c'est
un préfet même sur le plan du protocole
même sur le plan du protocole set ça
devient indécent indécent
moi je le ressens comme ça en tout cas
un ministre au quai un sous préfet un
directeur de service social je sais pas
si si si on mesure les pistes d un
psychiatre ne décrirai mieux que moi
mais imaginez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur nos territoires où le
président de la région bourgogne le
président d'un des départements de
bourgogne ayant financé la totalité de
tel ou tel équipement sportif scolaire
industriels etc doivent s'incliner
devant le sous-préfet du coin qui parle
après eux pour dire le mot de l'état qui
n'a pas mis un centime
non mais qu'on compte sur le sur le plan
sur le plan purement de psychiatric quoi
quelque part ça démontre dans quel état
d'infériorité la démocratie et par
rapport à l'appareil technocratique
français vous discutez avec un
psychiatre ou un ti cesser notre système
d'organisation des montres
l'asservissement intellectuelle
financier politique à l'égard du monde
administratif c'est plus possible de
continuer ça s'ils n'en avaient jamais
adultes
la france c'est tanguy qui à rester chez
ses parents donc il faut qu'on trouve le
moyen d'accompagner des mers faut qu'on
trouve le moyen d'accompagner
l'intercommunalité mais faut qu'on a su
tant qu on assumera pas france ne se
redressera pas je veux dire regardez la
dégradation que nous avons dans un
certain nombre position de la france
dans lé rapport pisa position de la
france par rapport à la
désindustrialisation où la
désindustrialisation par rapport au
commerce extérieur par rapport au budget
de l'état
regardez toutes les statistiques est-ce
que c'est sous prétexte qu'on a réussi
une grande école et j'ai pu en réussir
une aussi
si on est on serait supérieur à un élu
démocratiquement élu refuge d'une petite
commune et je le jeu je ressens ça à
titre personnel comme beaucoup comme une
humiliation
alors je reviens à votre question parce
que là c'était de l'ordre psychologique
et région département moi honnêtement il
semble que l'état a plus vocation à être
au niveau départemental pour des raisons
de sécurité pour ses compétences de
sécurité de deux voilà au niveau
régional animation économique
développement économique tout ça c'est
la région moi je suis assez radical je
viens je conçois pas qu'il existe encore
des préfets dans notre pays et il
n'existe pas en espagne en n'existe pas
en allemagne n existe pas en italie
pourquoi il en existe en france encore
aujourd'hui en 2011 mais je vais plus
loin nommé sas et c'est mon sentiment
personnel 1 je ne dis pas que c'est le
sentiment de la f1 du fait de la récup
et rencontrer des contraintes et
difficultés partie mais c'est tout là
toute la difficulté que j'essayais
d'exprimer tout à l'heure encore une
fois les expériences
c'est quoi les compétences partagées
avec l'état
c'est des compétences avec le rectorat
je dirais que ça va à peu près mais on
vient on vient pour parler trivialement
à loos
aujourd'hui on arrive à l'os ce qui fait
que tous les financements de la région
sur la modernisation des lycées
professionnels et un nos collègues le
disait ce matin j'ai même pas si c'était
martin malvy ou toit d un
j'ai trois millions inutilisés ici 4
millions d'utiliser là sur ce que l'état
m'a demandé de faire je sais pas si
c'est la rgpp ou si c'est la volonté de
réforme du ministère de l'éducation sur
le lycée honnêtement ce que ce que
j'observe c'est qu'on arrive à peu près
à s'entendre avec les services du
ministère de l'éducation sur la
mutualisation des compétences partagées
quant il s'agit de maintenir l'appareil
électronique ou internet des lycées sur
des choses très concrètes mais j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on va
arriver à loos parce que on va avoir
l'impression en à l'impossibilité déjà
pour l'éducation nationale de ne
remplacer les profs parents ce qui nous
semble grave à nous région qui sommes en
train de mettre en place des dispositifs
d'orientation
l'idée des régions c'est de mettre en
place un service public de l'orientation
de la formation et de l'emploi
ces choses étant tellement liés inutile
de 2,2 de rappeler qu'une formation
choisie par une bonne orientation c'est
une formation réussie à une formation
réussie c'est habituellement un emploi
trouver le modèle québécois modèle
canadien l'a l'a démontré sauf
qu'aujourd'hui
l'absence de formation des enseignants
et de formation permanente des
enseignants alors même que les
enseignants sont quand même comme dans
les autres pays on repère la base de
l'orientation
ça nous pose des problèmes à nous région
mais ça c'est pas un problème d'hergé
pépé c'est un problème de heal de
politique sur les autres compétences de
la région formation l'apprentissage
emploi développement économique
non moi je jauge je ressens le problème
plutôt à l'envers ou des services de
l'état veulent s'occuper de chantiers
notamment sur l'emploi et sur les
territoires dont ils n'ont plus les
moyens ni matériel ni humain
d'appréhender donc je vois plutôt pour
répondre à la question de françois je
vois plutôt le problème le problème en
creux mais on n'a pas les mêmes
problèmes que les petites communes que
les communes en règle générale mais
encore une fois
moi je maintiens que le problème de la
rgpp
si on ne le pose pas en termes de
dassier ainsi un terme de qui fait quoi
qui est responsable de quoi on peut pas
apporter une réponse quand une fois
l'air gpp n'a pas été logique
sur un strict plan de l'organisation
passionnel des moyens d'une gouvernance
sur le territoire il est totalement
stupide de voir le nombre de policiers
et gendarmes diminuer le nombre de juges
ne pas progresser suffisamment le nombre
de profs diminuait est de voir l'état à
maintenir des services sur des
compétences qui ont été transférées aux
régions et aux départements
c'est grotesque encore une fois je
reviens à ma formule initiale il suffit
de les exprimer
pour montrer que c'est stupide quant à
dire mais les services de l'état sont
les garants de l'égalité du territoire
cet anime ans éclats de rire qui peut
répondre 7
à cette interrogation quand les régions
pris la responsabilité des formations
sanitaires et sociales
c'était un immense foutoir avec une
égale une inégalité départementale entre
les départements d'une même région qui
était incompréhensible
la dotation des lycées anthos gérer ou
des collèges géré par l'état chris était
un clientélisme achevée donc voilà
on était dit je vais vous citer un
exemple extraordinaire qui se passe dans
le département de l'ain et notamment
dans le franco valdo genevois
les emplois sont que tu es france haute
savoie et un les emplois pardon ce côté
suisse et les travailleurs eux
franchissent la frontière ils sont cotés
haute savoie est un don qu'il ya des
problèmes de transport invraisemblable
parce qu'il faut franchir les frontières
n'existent plus enfin plus vraiment mais
rien est adaptée dans faut trouver des
solutions
donc il ya des solutions qui sont
imaginés par la région par la région
quand c'est le ferroviaire et puis par
d'autres comme sait les trams le
département par exemple ou le transport
route le l'ensemble du système sur le
franco valdo genevois c'est à peu près
110 120 millions d'euros alors le préfet
de région sur car en caux et dis moi je
vais régler ça
pas de problème mais j'ai pas un sou
voilà c'est extraordinaire comme il a
tenu ce discours devant de tous les
décident de rhône alpes
donc voilà donc je suis là pour écouter
on va faire quelque chose mais j'ai donc
voilà bel exemple est alors arrivé je
vais vous aider à en trouver
alors moi je voudrais simplement dire
une petite chose concernant le niveau
territorial pertinents région
département
je crois que quand on pose la question
comme ça on répond on à proust mal
quelle région
et quel département parce que si c'est
rhône-alpes 6 millions cinq cent mille
habitants
c'est pas tout charente ou franche comté
ou même bourgogne la question n'a plus
le même sens que je dis alors moi quelle
est la pertinence à ce propos à ce
niveau là je réponds pas je dis
simplement que le département est une
que collectivité territoriale de
proximité que la région bon suivant son
importance peut avoir des actions comme
c'est ronald aps
à l'international les actions fortes à
l'international c'est pas le cas de la
franche comté
je vais pas en bourgogne donc voilà donc
là on ne répond pas mais je vous
rappeler quand même que la rgpp c'était
pour réduire les coûts d'ailleurs tu
l'as bien dit enfin tu le suggérer
c'était pour réduire les coûts en fait
c'est pas pour réduire les coûts c'est
les transférer parce que moi ce que je
constate dans le département c'est que
les services de l'état bien sûr n'existe
plus passons sur les tribunaux de
commerce et autres mais les services que
rendent est l'état à travers la dde
l'ancienne dde par exemple mais d'autres
n'existent plus donc les communes soit
se retourne vers le privé pour ensemble
de soi se retourne vers le département
en disant qu est ce que vous nous
proposez donc on transfère les coûts aux
communes aux départements si le
département décide
moi j'ai fait ensemble de campagne comme
vous tous j'imagine donc lorsqu'on
demandait c'était une assistance
juridique par exemple parce que les
communes n'ont pas toujours les moyens
en plus l'intercommunalité elle peut
être réduite certaines prérogatives
certains choix qu'ils ont fait ils n'ont
pas toujours non plus les moyens donc
sept ans tournait vers le département
donc il ya eu un transfert des coûts de
l'état vers les collectivités
territoriales c'est comme ça que moi je
les ai vécus que je vis encore
aujourd'hui
dans notre département alors après pour
le problème de la pertinence et moi je
pense qu'il faudra revenir sur
effectivement qui fait quoi et quand on
parle de choses vraiment le plus sérieux
je ne sais pas comment ça va se passer
dans les années à venir je sais la
parole à mon collègue si l'ennui
lapandry président de conseil général
mais il faudra bien sûr dire qui fait
quoi au niveau des régions au niveau
département c'est un vieux débat
mais faudra bien qu'on y arrive un jour
et puis que fait l'état dans tout ça les
préfets sous-préfets le préfet
maintenant il a pu voix au chapitre moi
je constate que chez moi c'est plutôt le
préfet de région qui annoncent qu'ils se
déplacent dans l'ain parce que c'est la
règle il doit avertir le préfet de l'ain
qu'il est dans la et c'est avec lui que
je travaille pas vrai partout et voir
c'est comme ça que ça se passe pour les
dossiers importants
et puis bon les sous-préfets la limite
ont un rôle de conseil auprès des
communes quasiment encore un peu
possible les maires ont parfois recours
aux compétences
j'irai juridique des sous-préfets
recommencer vécu chez moi comment je le
vis chez moi dans le département par
département exceptionnel vas-y oui très
très brièvement
merci enfin moi je suis très très très
heureux de ce que vous nous c'est de la
merde vous nous parlez de large et pépé
je dirais presque que c'est une des plus
belle plaidoirie que j'ai eue pour rgpp
sauf que on ne part pas sur les sur les
mêmes bases des sceaux lui même
projection ni avec les mêmes objectifs
et donc pas ce moment là on la leyre gp
telle qu'elle est tel qu'il nous est
décrite par les personnes qui ont
auditionné jusqu'à maintenant c'est
absolument pas celle qui vu les départs
vous auquel j'adhère pour ma part
complètement parce que je trouve
qu'effectivement on a besoin de beaucoup
de réformes
il faut savoir effectivement qui fait
quoi où comment etc
et alors vous avez vous avez dit tout à
l'heure assez assez justement que les
sous-préfectures ma foi
vous avez plus grande utilité même été
jusqu aux préfectures ceci étant c'est
ce qui nous est dit puisque on nous dit
aujourd'hui la rgpp alors de manière
triviale
effectivement on est rendus jusqu'à l'os
et si on continue fera maintenant
supprimer les sous préfectures
alors c'est de l'autre côté on nous dit
non non absolument pas c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne touchera pas ce sont les
sous préfectures donc on voit bien que
là il ya un enjeu important
mais plus qu'un enjeu moi la question
j'ai envie de vous poser c'est quel
avenir pour les territoires ruraux
parce que si les maires s'accroche aussi
désespérément alors sous préfecture
c'est parce que une fois que celle ci
auront sauté il ne restera plus rien et
malheureusement la décentralisation
telle que on la voudrait n'est
absolument pas abouti et les loin de
l'être
il ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
beaucoup travail de formation aussi
auprès des élus et donc d'un côté on a
une décentralisation qui n'est pas
abouti d'une culture qui ne s'est pas
mise en place et de l'autre côté des
défunts pas complètement tous les cas on
le voit à travers nos intercommunalités
suprême de l'ingénierie aujourd'hui il
ya encore peu d'intercommunalité qui
sont prêts à se saisir de cette question
là en disant on va se doter des bons
services pour accompagner nos communes
dans le besoin qui est le leur de d'état
devant des gens compétents pour les
contrats etc
les services des travaux les élus etc et
donc la sous préfecture c'est un peu le
dernier bastion c'est la dernière
considération de l'état vis-à-vis de ces
petites communes qui voient leur école
leur échapper leur maison de retraite
laure échapper les hôpitaux locaux
c'est judiciaire et deux parties la
sécurité voilà et donc attention à la
manière dont on opère les glissements
d'une chose vers une autre mais en tous
les cas moi je souhaiterais avoir votre
avis un petit peu sur comment le
territoire de demain peut s'organiser
tout en prenant en compte une rgpp est
une organisation qui leur donne un
espoir d'avenir
ces présidents alors je commence
bon le qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important pour un territoire rural créer
une maison de santé
défendre un hôpital maison de retraite
ou avoir un sous préfet oui je veux dire
lol il suffit de poser là encore une
fois il suffit de poser la question qui
a créé les maisons de santé qui
permettent d'éviter la déprise c'est la
politique contractuelle des régions et
parfois certains départements enfin moi
je vous fais j'en suis à ma deuxième
maison de santé en aquitaine donc enfin
je veux dire et c'est pas les services
de l'état qui ont proposé cette idée que
le ministère aujourd'hui ils reprennent
cette idée je peux vous dire que les
maisons de santé saliens des élus la
politique de la ville ça vient des élus
les politiques de réinsertion ça vient
des élus fait tant qu'on n'aura pas
confiance en nous mêmes et qu'on sera
subjugué par des hauts fonctionnaires
qui se regroupent dans les ministères on
s'en sortira pas bon sang de bois
enfin je viens c'est un problème de
confiance en soi c'est tanguy encore une
fois on sorte chez ses parents en botte
le cul à ses enfants pour qu'ils sortent
de chez nous quand ils ont 20 ans quand
il pour qu'ils travaillent pour qu'ils
réussissent leurs études et nous en
reste sous sous l'autorité d'un sous
préfet parce qu'il invite tous les 15
jours ou toutes les trois semaines
quelqu'un à la sous préfecture
non mais enfin alors qu'ils ont plus
d'argent maintenant on supprime même des
voitures ou sous préfets mais moi
j'aurai alors je ressens ça d'une
manière physique ça suppose on dit mais
l'intercommunalité a passé forte mais en
même temps on refuse l'intercommunalité
quand même un petit problème quoi c'est
pour ça que je parlais de syndrome de
stockholm tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'on refuse la responsabilité c'est à
dire que l'appareil démocratique que
l'on nous représentation nationale est
censé représenter en refuse qu'elle
aille jusqu'au bout de la responsabilité
on attend que quelqu'un ici
de l'état mais moi je suis désolé
président d'une région j'estime que je
fais partie de l'état se représente
l'état comme le maire j'ai été maire
j'estime que je représente l'état plus
que le préfet dans ce que l'état
comporte de droit d'action donc c'est un
débat c'est un débat philosophique mais
qui en même temps un débat opérationnel
quand une fois qu'est ce qu'on veut
préserver
est-ce qu'on veut préserver un sous
préfet qui a plus de pouvoir plus de
moyens ou est-ce qu'on veut préserver
l'hôpital le tribunal de commerce le
prof
le flic les vrais services publics suis
complètement d'accord sauf que j'ai le
sentiment en tout cas des coûts de ce
que me disent les mères c'est que la
possibilité de préserver de la santé de
l'enseignement qui terrasse sur leur
territoire est lié aussi au fait que au
maintien des services de l'état alors
sans doute que non mais il sait quelque
chose qui qu'il faut travailler mais
d'ailleurs ces cultures vous expliquer
tout à l'heure c'est culturel peux vous
dire qu'à marmande dans le
lot-et-garonne
on a supprimé le tribunal de commerce
même si à sous préfet j'aurais préféré
que le sous-préfet disparaissent et
qu'on maintienne le tribunal de commerce
de dire si on propose pas ce que tout le
problème quand même dans par rapport à
la rgpp c'est clair gpp vient d'en haut
viendront dans un dialogue assez opaques
entre quelques organisations syndicales
les grands corps et un ou deux ministres
j'ai participé la seule chose auquel
j'ai participé à quelques j'ai participé
moi en tant que président de la rfef
c'est un débat organisé par les échos
avec les grands directeurs de
l'administration centrale
à un moment donné donc directeur du
trésor directeur de la fonction publique
qui avaient ils étaient tous là et un de
vos collègues
à présider une mission je j'oublie le
nom qui est passé à la cour des comptes
lambert a peut-être présidé la
commission la plus intéressante que nous
ayons eu entre les associations d'élus
et l'administration centrale
parce que les trois présidents des
associations d'élus était enfin en phase
si j'allais dire si j'ose dire ne le
prenais poney le avec un peu d'humour de
l'adversaire c'est à dire c'était pas
simplement des élus qui étaient en face
plus ou moins instrumentalisé comme nous
le sommes tous
c'étaient les directeurs
d'administration centrale du trésor
la fonction publique des impôts etc et
qui défend des leur job leurs services
leurs corps et à un moment donné le
directeur du trésor mme défend un
système qui est de dire mais regardez
c'est les collectivités locales qu'on
fait exploser depuis entre 85 et 2005 la
fonction publique territoriale et c'est
vrai les intercommunalités
compte tenu des nouvelles normes de
l'eau des nouvelles normes de transport
etc ont fait exploser le nombre des
fonctionnaires dans l'intercommunalité
on peut pas le nier mais c'est pas les
régions les départements qui ont fait
exploser
sauf que le véritable la véritable
horreur qui avaient dansé qu'entre 1985
et 2005 au moment où on était en pleine
décentralisation l'augmentation des
fonctionnaires de l'état étaient 270
mille personnes au moment où on
transfère au département l'équipement la
dde reste au niveau de l'état par
réticences syndicales par réticences
syndicales réticences nous quand on veut
nous transférer les tos aujourd'hui les
tos ne veulent plus revenir à l'état
réticences quand on vous nous transférer
les le personnel dit d'orientation
aujourd'hui il regrette de pas être venu
à la
sous l'autorité de la région parce
qu'ils sont en train de diminuer
l'époque donc je veux dire voilà ce
qu'il est préférable
il suffit de poser la question
d'ailleurs pour y répondre si l'état
doit limiter ses moyens et puis faut pas
parce que quand même on a passé notre
bac les uns les autres
certains ont même fait des études
supérieures excusez moi de le dire moi
mon directeur des services par rapport
au sous-préfet de je sais plus quelle
ville qui étaient d'anciens directeurs
des sports n'a de 2,2 des hauts-de-seine
ou de nice qui a été nommé sous préfet
je sais en qui j'ai confiance pour
conseiller les collectivités locales
bon mais entre développer la gendarmerie
de marmande et supprimer la
sous-préfecture de marmande ou supprimer
le le le tribunal de commerce de
marmande et lycées est sous préfecture
le choix est vite fait donc voilà mais
moi je vais je suis plus loin tu le sais
je sais alors sur la dde est un cas
typique
je sais plus et toi qu'il posait tout la
d2 est un cas typique
je veux dire on à transférer cette
compétence au département et pourquoi en
entrant on y transfère pas les moyens en
quoi
mais d'abord historiquement c'était pas
l'état qui s'occupait d'eux venait
d'être cantonniers s'occuper des idées
des routes etc
ces thèmes les collectivités locales qui
s'en occupait en quoi un département est
pas capable de le faire
en quoi un département n'est pas capable
de conseiller une commune enfin je veux
dire bah faut le faire et alors il faut
pas se plaindre surtout faut pas se
plaindre faut pas dire mais il m'a pas
donné assez d'argent
il faut prendre la responsabilité
arrêtons de nous présenter en génisses
mans complet par rapport à un état que
l'on exècre mais en même temps dont on
demande la protection assumons enfin
pardon de le dire mais c'est un problème
de culture
j'ai discuté un jour avec le président
de la catalogne
j'ai discuté avec le président de la
catalogne voix qui me disait en espagne
même problème quand on évoque avec vous
sauf que quand on nous transfère une
compétence on ne se plaint pas on
l'apprend parce qu'on sait que c'est
d'abord avec les compétences qu'on aura
les moyens et pâle inverse
parce que si tu attends la fia réforme
de la fiscalité pour prendre des
compétences tu l'aura jamais le déclic
en 1980 pour le transfert de la
décentralisation
ça a été on transfère l'exécutif au
président du conseil général et régional
je l' ai vécu j'étais directeur d'une
région à l'époque ça a tout changé
aujourd'hui quel est le transfert par
rapport à l'état c'est le le cd
compétences plus importante parce qu on
les gère mieux en les germes et e on les
gère bien mieux donc arrêtons de nous
plaindre
en plus c'est à dire on a peut-être une
petite contradiction et c'est une chose
que je qu'on peut pas qu'on partage avec
françois patriat
c'est qu'on peut pas à la fois se
plaindre et puis dire on veut garder la
clause de compétence générale et vouloir
tout faire
je pense que dans tous les pays d'europe
dans tous les pays d'europe l'autonome
pardon de le dire peut-être un peu
j'observe ce qui se passe c'est que
l'autonomie fiscale a quand même
largement diminué non région la plus on
souhaite avoir un peu plus d'autonomie
fiscale
mais le modèle européen aujourd'hui
c'est une part d'impôts d'état on peut
pas nous avoir le beurre et l'argent du
beurre
le pouvoir la clause de compétence
générale et se plaindre par rapport à
des responsabilités qui nous seraient
transférés si on continue comme ça on va
rester pieds et poings liés
c'est de gérer un endroit
ceci moi je moi je me plains jamais je
suis vêtements comme le président il
faut avancer parce que les nos
concitoyens 6,1 à 50% qui vont pas voter
et 20% de ceux qui votent votre front
national c'est aussi parce qu'ils ont
ils leur manquent aussi de repères et
donc on a besoin de tracer des
perspectives
sauf que là où le raisonnement à mon
avis achoppent c'est pour les
départements aujourd'hui quand le social
représente 64% du compte administratif
mois entremont budget j'ai fait en 2005
social pour le département de la drôme
140 millions d'euros et le budget que
j'ai fait en 2011 250 millions d'euros
110 millions d'euros de plus en cinq
exercices pour l'année 2010 chambre
régionale des comptes
l'année 2009 change de décompte l'état
nous doit 37 millions d'euros sur le
social il arrive à un moment où nous
sommes obligés parce que notre
autofinancement baisse par rapport au
social ne plus pouvoir aider les
communes dans l'ingénierie ce que l'on
fait et c'est donc on va être amené à
revenir là dessus
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que on n'est pas là pour se plaindre on
est là pour réclamer notre dû sur les
allocations sociales ce sont des
allocations universelles qu'une version
au nom de l'état et l'état ne respecte
pas son engagement constitutionnel c'est
tout mais il reste se partage à 100 nous
nous avons d'abord on a perdu plus
d'autonomie fiscale que les départements
clés commune on a plus que la carte
grise qui représente à peu près 7% et
nous on en plus la chance d'avoir un
état qui vient nous dire vous voulez une
ligne à grande vitesse alors certains
départements sont un peu impacté mais
moins que les régions et moi je vois en
aquitaine si je veux avoir la lgv je
mets une année notre budget
d'investissement donc alors ça me tue
tout et vous voulez rénové l'université
vous payez enfin je vais bien on est
c'est donc on a aussi d'autres
contraintes
donc c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas tenir
c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas tenir dans
le cadre d'une d'une répartition des
compétences qu'ils soient pas clairs
qu'ils soient pas claires
aujourd'hui
merci le président on a débordé moi même
une autre commission et puis ils vous
invitent et qui attendait tout cas merci
de la franchise des propos
merci la hauteur de vue aussi et puis de
cette vision un peu différente nous
coller bondi de 2 lat de la rgpp sur les
collectivités les régions étant à
parents m'ont moins impactés c'est vrai
dans la relation collectivités on
travaille peu avec l'état et ses
services travaillent avec le sgar nous
comme travail claude garou le préfet
directement mais peu avec les services
donc c'est complètement différent mais
en tout cas merci de cette vision et du
temps passé ici qu'il faut sommes les
yeux alors on sait le président de
l'association des régions de france
étaient donc auditionné par la mission
d'information sénatoriale sur les
conséquences de la rgpp sur les
collectivités territoriales
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire c'est à 19 heures et à 22
heures elle très bonne journée sur
public sénat